well with joe lombardo running for  governor clark county is in need of a  new sheriff three police veterans were  vying for the top cop spot former  undersheriff kevin mcmahon won by a  landslide with more than half the vote  he's getting about 60 percent there he  served with metro for decades we talked  to him about the win  my message has been one of keeping the  crime low in this community and i know  how to do that i was the undersheriff  for six years i did 30 years in law  enforcement and i chose to come back and  put myself through that because i care  about this community and i'm going to  make a big difference  nick mahel's promising now to support  officers mental health and keep the city  safe so visitors feel comfortable coming  here